good afternoon everyone my name is dr
miller
and the scp we're going to be looking at
today
is scp-3359
object class ketter
special containment procedures
provisional site 90 has been established
over the entrance of scp-3359
in order to restrict access to 3359
and to contain any instances of
scp-33591
scp-3359 is monitored at all times
and any sightings of scp-33591 within it
are to be reported to the current site
manager no personnel are permitted into
scp-3359 without written approval from
at least
three level three clearance personnel
scp-33591 is held in a standard humanoid
containment cell
also monitored at all times any attempts
by scp-3359-1 at
corporeal destruction are to be halted
by an on-site security team
every 30 days following transformation
into desiccated form
scp-33591 is to be removed from scp-3359
and submerged in a 2.5 kiloliter tank of
water until fully hydrated
a process taking approximately 24 hours
once full hydration is completed
scp-33591 can be returned to its
containment cell
as a reminder rehydration is a privilege
and not a necessity scp-33591
is not to be rehydrated following
repeated attempts at self-destruction
and reversion to its desiccated form at
the project manager's discretion
this does not affect the scheduled
rehydration established
every 30 days closed or unobserved
spaces with a volume large enough to
hold scp-33591
approximately 65 liters are not
permitted within a 90 meter radius of
scp-3359
all rooms within this radius are to be
monitored in the case of attempted
escape
by scp-33591
description scp-3359
is a room built of stone approximately
20 meters underground
the room itself is approximately 5.5 by
8 meters with a ceiling 7 meters high
the walls of scp-3359 are covered in
egyptian hieroglyphics
and designate the room as a tomb
notably there are no traces of any
sarcophagus or any similar structure
within scp-3359
the contents of scp-3359 consists mainly
of randomly spaced bowls of
food typically this includes breads
dried fish
onions dried lentils figs and dates
dating reveals the bowls to be made
around 2500
bce food present within scp-3359 does
not rot
or decompose though removing food from
scp-3359 will cause it to decompose at a
normal rate
if a bowl is removed from scp-3359
a new bowl identical in shape will
manifest containing food
inside scp-3359 approximately 24 hours
after removal similarly food removed
from scp-3359 will re-manifest in sign
of cp-3359
approximately 24 hours after removal
scp-33591 is a humanoid entity
created by consumption of foods within
scp-3359
causation between food consumption and
entity transformation
has been proven in addendum 3359-04
when a subject enters scp-3359 and
consumes any food within
they begin transformation into
scp-3359-1
the large stone door initially set at
the entrance of scp-3359
moves to seal its entrance with immense
force regardless of the door's location
at this point video logs reveal the
subject rapidly entering a state of
severe desiccation
though the means of desiccation remain
unknown the subject's skin
rapidly shrivels as muscle deteriorates
the subject remains living and sentient
throughout the entire process
once the process finishes the door to
scp-3359
reopens analysis of scp-33591 reveals a
severe limitation
or complete lack of bodily fluids
including water
blood saliva and urine any amount of
liquid that comes into contact with
scp-33591
less than 2.5 kiloliters has little to
no effect
scp-33591 absorbs any liquids that come
into contact with its body
but does not show signs of rehydration
unless immediately exposed
to 2.5 or more kiloliters of fluid
despite this scp-33591 exhibits
remarkable strength beyond average human
limits
tempered by considerable slowness
scp-33591 has proven able to perform
activity
at faster rates but these bursts of
activity typically only last
seconds and are uncommon unless
scp-3359-1 is pursuing prey testing on
the limits of scp-3359-1 strength
remains
inconclusive but it has proven able to
physically overpower a tactical response
team of three trained officers
scp-33591 exhibits aggressive behavior
towards any animals
particularly humans when brought into
visual contact with any animal life
scp-3359-1 will pursue the largest
organism available
primarily draining it of all its blood
and other bodily fluids
while partially consuming the body to
facilitate the process
scp-33591's absorption ability is
powerful enough to absorb bodily fluids
through
skin by touch alone notably scp-33591
does not aim to kill its prey
pursuing primarily the organism's body
fluids
scp-3315-m1 avoids crowded areas
and seeks isolated prey but makes no
effort to communicate
it is unknown if this lack of
communication is a result of low
intelligence or
voluntary denial scp-33591
uses ambush tactics to grapple prey
utilizing scp-3359's anomalous powers
scp-3359-1 returns to scp-3359
before sunrise though this appears to be
a matter of preference rather than a
necessity
and is active at night scp-3359-1
is aggressively territorial in regards
to scp-3359
when scp-3359-1 enters scp-3359
it disappears and reappears in any space
not currently observed by humans at a
range of 90 meters
from scp-3359 this ability has been used
by scp-3359-1 to escape containment
multiple times
see incident reports 33 59 1 3
and 4 and the containment procedures
have been updated to reflect this
the method of this transportation is
unknown and further research on the
methods of this instant transportation
is pending scp-33591 primarily uses this
effect
to ambush prey scp-3359-1 in its
desiccated state
shows no signs of aging in the case of
corporeal destruction
in which a majority of scp-33591's
physical matter is destroyed
scp-3315-m1's body reverts to dust
and a completed form appears within
scp-3350
in its desiccated state this new form
once rehydrated is identical to the one
previously destroyed
if scp-33591 in its desiccated state is
submerged in at least 2.5 kiloliters of
fluid
it rehydrates reverting to a physical
form resembling the affected subject
around the age of their early 20s the
rehydrated scp-33591
displays none of the traits exhibited by
the desiccated scp-3359-1
exhibiting full mental control and
proving to be for all measures
a normal human being except for its
anomalous aging capabilities
both instances of scp-33591 monitored by
the foundation
have exhibited little to no change in
personality in their rehydrated state
following transformation into scp-33591
besides the transformation related
trauma
scp-33591 in its rehydrated state
rapidly ages physically aging
approximately 60 years over the course
of 30 days
at the end of this period scp-33591
disappears and
reappears within scp-3359 in its
dehydrated state
addendum 3359-01
the first and current recorded instance
of scp-3359
referred to as scp-3359-1a
is a caucasian male exhibiting signs of
mental instability
due to lack of resonance and close
relatives cover-up activity for scp-3359
was not required scp-33591a has proven
uncooperative in foundation testing
and containment frequently attempting
self-destruction and reversion to its
desiccated state attempts at physical
recovery for scp-3359-1a
have been unsuccessful
addendum 3359-02
translation of the hieroglyphics within
scp-3359 have been completed and can be
found in document 3359-1
a synopsis of the text reveals a story
relating the anomalous properties of
scp-3359
into a mythological setting consistent
with ancient egypt
the writings show an unnamed individual
dying within scp-3359
and being taken to the judgment hall of
the afterlife by anubis
wherein osiris resides here the unnamed
individual presents a
phallic object to osiris who takes the
object
and rests the unnamed individual from
anubis's hands
transporting them back to scp-3359
now containing food offerings to the
dead
the unnamed individual is given a shield
like aura by osiris
which protects them from death the next
portion of the tale
involves anubis damaging this shield and
draining the unnamed individual of blood
the unnamed individual goes and drains
other people for their blood as a result
of this
the end of the tale shows the unnamed
individual in a healthier state
with the shield fixed as they stand atop
a mound of bodies
it is unknown how relevant this
information may be
in ascertaining the history of scp-3359
addendum 3359-3
during testing agent khaled approached
scp-3359
upon proximity to scp-3359
scp-3359-1 became agitated
and used its hands and fingernails which
it had sharpened into effective cutting
materials to
reforming in scp-3359 in its desiccated
state
scp-3359-1 immediately attacked agent
khaled
agent khaled remained alive for three
minutes before blood loss resulted in
exsanguination
director overseeing the operation
reprimanded for failure to contact site
security
addendum 3359.04
it has been proven that scp-33591 is
replaced
after a new subject enters scp-3359
and consumes any of the food within the
tomb
after agent muhammad entered scp-3359
on scp-3359-1a became visually
distressed
attempting self-destruction immediately
the attempt at self-destruction was
halted by on-site security
after consuming food within scp-3359
agent muhammad began expected
transformation
into scp-33591
during the process scp-3359-1a's body
began
disintegrating into fine dust these
events
deemed related would prove that there
can be only one scp-3359-1
at any given time agent mohammed
now referred to as scp-33591-b
is the current instance of scp-3359-1
interview 3359 1.
interviewed scp-3359-1a
interviewer dr
forward scp-33591a
following rehydration was questioned
regarding details on scp-3359
scp-3359-1a was interviewed in its cell
via intercom scp-33591's arabic speech
has been translated for distribution in
english-speaking branches
scp-3359-1 speech was slurred
and portions of it were incoherent
hello scp-3359-1a
so it says here that your name is seth
is this correct
[ __ ] you please remain civil and we can
get through this faster
now is your birth name seth hall
no name i understand but please
answer the question get me the [ __ ] out
of here
you know i can't do that we'll come back
to that question
now when did you first come into contact
with scp-3359
the [ __ ] alert i'm referring to the tomb
you entered
the one that brought you into this
predicament
could you speak up i'll kill you i'll
rip the skin from your bones
scp-33591a please
you know you can't do that in this
position it would be best for you to
cooperate
in order to finish this interview so
could you please describe the effects of
scp-3359
i can live forever i have a new life
the weak exist to die i defeat me
to let me live their red red plus please
remain focused
did you enter scp-3359 and eat the food
inside of it
scp-3359-1a attacked the walls of its
cell
and offered no response after
approximately eight minutes of agitation
scp-33591a continued the interview
fatigued it gave me food
i never have to worry about dying again
how much longer is this interview i have
a couple more questions
how long have you been involved with
scp-3359
damn questions the room let me live for
longer than anyone could care to
remember
damn it your people won't be looking at
their little cameras forever
tomb will free me your skin pierced in
your blood
scp 33591a answer the questions
how many people have you killed
so many but not enough i will reach
the bloody limit and gain real life
forever when the streets flow red
and the bodies lie dry in the streets
where i walk
and feed and live and be freed
forever among a bright moon and drive
that's enough
on another matter you need hydration to
convert to your normal human form
why do you only seek blood why not use
say the river you can eat dirt
why don't you go eat some damn grass you
[ __ ] idiot and tell me why you don't
do it
[ __ ] you [ __ ] cattle
i will rip you apart the questions will
now conclude
this interview is officially owned by
some people
waiting to be killed and let me live
i will kill and eat and
kill and ate osiris grant me
strength to consume the blood of these
weak bastards
your death will only power me
end interview interview 3359-2
interviewed scp-3359-1b
interviewer dr
forward scp-3359-1b
following rehydration was questioned
regarding the details about the
scp-3359-1 experience
due to good behavior scp-3359-1b
was allowed a face-to-face interview
outside of its cell
scp-3359-1b was restrained
and site security team remained on call
scp-3359-1b proved cooperative with the
foundation's requests
scp-33591-b for your ease
would you like to be called any other
name during the course of this interview
my name's samia you know this come on
and act like we've never met before
apologies samir just a formality
so please describe the transformation
experience of scp-3359
i'm in hell i die every 30 days
do you know what that's like i can't
lift like this
i constantly feel myself getting closer
to death each day
i was what 20 last week i got to be
almost 40 now
and i feel it god damn do i feel it
please continue this isn't life
i'm not really living i'm just
waiting to die before it can take over
and make me a monster
and that's the worst part of this
existence
elaborate i don't want to
i really don't want to but i know
wanting doesn't get you very far if
you're like me
you know the basics of what happens
every 30 days i disappear
a desiccated aberration appears in the
tomb with my body
and it's me don't get me wrong i know
everything i'm doing and i can't
control it so you are aware of your
actions
in your dehydrated state but you cannot
control them
please explain it's about thirst
there's a thirst in that dry dry body
more unbearable than you can ever think
all i know then
is that i need to drink blood is more
than anything else
all i can do is watch yes i kill people
rip them apart with my own hands
thank you that is enough information
this interview will be terminated and
you will be escorted back to yourself
wait
please don't go you need to do me a
favor
this isn't life
i know that i am living a fate worse
than death i'm living a fade
full of constant death i feel the pain
of dying every month
you don't understand what this feels
like
you never will so you owe me
end this let me die
put another agent through that tomb and
let me fall to dust
please there's nothing
i have ever wanted more
end log closing statement
scp-3359-1b has been deemed
ideal in continued containment
its application for has been denied
you know mummies never freaked me out as
a kid but whenever you see one actually
move
you will change your mind
okay uh i need to get a new pair of
pants so i'm gonna wrap this one up
thank you all for listening if indeed
you still are
and you're all dismissed goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
it's not a spoon corey barker
arbiter soul the morrigan
retalias drew peacock
fanama takeikik victoria clarkson
eric corbeage kawaii fire keeper
daniel joker corvus
king madding bryson
samurai corgis james
saba nj vujak
and justin day if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos
and some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash the vogue thank you
know